[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar achieving clinical quality for
human ipsc generation and expansion
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by melting biotech to learn more
visit miltennybiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
boris grieber
head of r d ipsc ct catalytic cell and
gene therapy
and dr chow
chow sheng product product manager
regenerative medicine miltenny biotech
boris and xiao you may now begin your
presentation
yeah so thank you very much for the for
the introduction um i'm happy today to
talk about our ongoing
activities at kaplan around the
ipscs
their generation
and
manipulation
so to start with i would just like to
give a brief
intro into
the the ipc add-on to catalan so this
was a recent acquisition basically
done last year
so
the original company was called reinsert
located here in the cologne dusseldorf
metropolitan area and and our aim here
was to
generate a clinical great
universal starting material so i guess
cells under gmp conditions
um to form the basis for future
workflows in in cell therapy and
now being part of catalan i think this
uh really creates new opportunities not
only for
for our side here but
also vice versa to really um
harness the full potential of these of
these cells so for example we have
extensive manufacturing capabilities now
in within capitalism
as well as in in
our site in belgium in gothelys
even for commercial scale
cell therapy manufacturing beyond the
phase three clinical trials
and
in turn
i think we can really profit now from
the resources that there are in within
in
catholic uh for example the plasmid
manufacturing at gmp
um quality as well as other modalities
which can now serve as
well
a
agents in gmp workflows yeah using rkc
so we really hope to to create these
kind of synergies
um
yeah at cutland now
um so what i would like to focus on now
is the the manufacturing workflow so as
we have set it up with the
with the ipscs
and also highlights the
the pipeline for quality control
that we've set up
and and also come to talk about the
starting material
that we use here in the manufacturing
process later on i will talk about um
more
current and ongoing activities in terms
of
differentiation
of the ipscs and
development of future workflows
and also come to talk about the strategy
the overall strategy for for
reprogramming
so the manufacturing workflow is based
on a
rather simple workflow using episode
programming we try to keep things simple
and robust here really
and to make sure that
programming experiments
workflows
really work
um every time we perform them and
this is all done with the i guess blue
medium from
miltoni and at the time i can say
it was one of two media on the market
gmp great um
ipsc media
on the market and we compared this
against each other and simply found that
that the ips blue medium was superior so
we stick to that and and builds the
workflow
based on that on that medium
otherwise we are
using xeno-free cultural conditions
chemically defined culture conditions as
you would expect from a gmp workflow
and like i said keep things really
actually quite simple and
and manual
so
the workflow starts with the import of
hamburg stem cells from collaborating
corporate facility so this is gmp great
starting material and
we um
then introduce this into our
clean room facility here in in the
building
to then subject itself to reprogramming
and
this will give rise to
single lines single colonies
that are that are being isolated and
grown up to to
independent cell lines
so we are establishing several cell
lines for each donor and
within
making a
quality assessment and proceed with one
selected clones while we
freeze the
stocks of these of these candidate
clones so keep them
for potential later use
but this one selected cell lines then
then
drawn thrown up and
until the the vectors they that are used
for reprogramming are fully eliminated
and
finally the
cells are expanded and cry preserved um
and all the qc is obviously taking place
or most of the qc
is taking place and outside the clean
room facility in dedicated
qc labs
so the qcss can be subdivided into
different categories if you if you will
into safety related
um essays into assets looking at genomic
integrity of the cells and
into essays that
address cell type specific
characteristics so um differentiation
potential of the of the ipad cells for
example
so we're trying to address these uh all
these these important points
using a panel of
assets and i would just like to
highlight a few examples
so this is
showing you uh in process controls that
are carried out
in the clean room
so uh we're taking samples at regular
intervals and really use strategies um
tachman based assays to to verify that
the that the vectors are becoming
eliminated over time
in the cells and only if we observe that
repeatedly over several passages we
would
switch over to amplifying the cells and
try preserving
another important issue is the genomic
integrity like i
mentioned so we're doing on the one hand
classical karyotyping
following international standards for
tumor diagnostics
um
so this involves
numerical analysis as well the
structural ones
using multiple metaphase splits
but in addition to that we also using
full genomic sequencing to assess the
mutation load in these cells and to rule
out the function mutations
in cancer associated genes for example
so um on the right hand side you've seen
analysis in this regard where we also
revealed that the mutation load in our
lines is tends to be rather low so you
see before before data points on the
right hand side
in comparison to
ips cells derived from adult starting
material so we could really trace this
down to to the to the starting material
which is i think implies really a key
advantage of
here using using chord blood
um yeah and with regards to the specific
properties of the ips cells
we're certainly assessing
differentiation potential in in several
ways on the one hand of course in the
in the gmp
qc workflow
where we mostly you know look at
same spontaneous differentiation
but we're also developing and our
clients are testing cells for
directed differentiation
and capability so we um have generated
endothelial cells from these from these
lines as well as pure rpe cells with a
with a new protocol that we've developed
and we've also subjected these cells to
to cardiac induction
it's in high efficiency in all cases
so we're quite happy with these with the
properties of these cells indeed
just briefly um to
summarize the points about the starting
material that that's i already mentioned
in part and so we think that chord
product is a
the preferred starting material for for
reprogramming ips cells for clinical use
uh first of all because it's a
clinical
material by itself it's used for for
therapeutic purposes and
as such it's uh it's extensively
pre-tested for viral
contaminations for example
so we're building on that on that
material and
another biological
argument is really the the
fact that these cells are neonatal so
the mutation load in the
in the in that material is really is
really low and that
translates into the rga cells as i try
to indicate
um now in the final part i would just
like to highlight a few
workflows that we've that we're working
on so we're not
building
on what we have basically on the ipscs
we would like to
establish differentiation protocols and
stream compatible workflows
on that basis and i would also like to
highlight the
the overall strategy we use for
generating the
the ips cells and um
i'd like to start with that aspect so as
you know um
when
setting up an allergenic
um approach based on magpies sees you
you you you will face the issue of
immune rejection simply because um donor
and recipient are not identical and the
cells are easily becoming rejected in
the in the patient
under normal circumstances so there are
approaches needed really to address that
issue because immune suppression
which could of course be applied but
always comes with
side effects
quite severe side effects actually
so
our strategy to address this
issue is to use
hba homozygous
donors
as a starting material so these are
um
it's a rare um
condition in the population to be
actually homozygous uh this occurs
at really low frequency and then we are
sort of speak cherry picking our quad
blood bank for these for these
privileged individuals
because
using hla homozygous cells as indicated
here with these color codes
really simplifies the the challenge of
immune matching so it's much easier to
find
matching recipient patients using hla
homozygous cells because you only need
to consider
one of the two
parental
h layer layers for each gene
is shown here indicated here with these
color codes
of course i should also
mention
complementary strategies
to achieve immune compatibility and gene
editing is the most prominent one
in this regard so you can think of
manipulating hla genes as well as other
genes
to make the cells immune compatible to
basically any
potential recipient in the population
and there are also hybrid approaches
where
you're using hva homozygous cells as a
starting
source and then do a partial
deletion of the hla genes for example so
to enhance their immune compatibility
and so i think
these are these these different
approaches sorry they are definitely not
competing they're complementary
and in fact we think that the hla
homozygous rpss that we've generated
would also present a great starting
material for
for
enhancing the applicability of these
science by gene editing
so but
again
discussing the the homozygous ancient
homozygous approach
um so these are some calculations that
we performed uh where
um basically
compatibility of the
cells to the population is plotted
against the
individual
genotypes the hla hypotypes
and these are linked here according to
frequency in the population so you
you see the most frequent edgelight
haplotypes on the left
of the of the lesson chart and you can
infer from such calculations that
you just need a handful of uh or maybe
10 satellites or so to
in in our case to
uh to basically match every second
patient in the population which i think
would be would be great
um like i said gene editing can also
help to ensure increase the
matchability
in the population and also
you know obtain access to other
populations
so
um
yeah the overall applicability of these
cell lines could
could be enhanced this way
on the right hand side you see the
current status where we are so we see
that we basically have access to the
most frequent hyper types
um
making this strategy i think a viral
a viable one
but we've also learned really over the
last years that other things play a role
as well
and an important point here is really
donor eligibility so qualification of
donors
um
uh in terms of you know regulatory uh
requirements in the us on the in the
european union
uh as well as in japan
and for example um so we're trying to
really explicitly uh match these
requirements with new uh cell lines so
for the existing sublimes we what we
have to do is basically take what we
have
because we're using the hla um
homozygous approach so we need to use
really existing material for that and um
for that reason we
um we
had to develop mitigation strategies
here for these existing cell lines
comprehensive ones strong ones we think
but
um
like i said as a complimentary strategy
i think we would also now like to
really fully fulfill these requirements
from the start with new zealand
so then just a few more slides on the
current translation activities uh so we
are we are working to
to establish efficiency improve
protocols um
that could form
the basis for future gmp workflows
for ipsl
differentiation
so generation of interesting cell types
some types of clinical importance so the
embassies
are one example
we have developed a simple one factor
based protocol here very robust
um and and fast also
the the msc like cells that we generate
expressed typical
msc markers and they show extensive
proliferation potential
uh as an example so we we hope to be
able to generate cell banks of these
mscs soon to be able to to offer them to
to potential partners and clients
another example is immune cell
differentiation and so we um we
acknowledge really the growing interest
in cancer
immunotherapy based on its cells
and we think so that's the
existing protocols are not
are not really uh perfect uh perhaps we
definitely have potential for further
improvement and
what we do what we're doing here is we
are trying to really
optimize also the early stages of
differentiation
so the initial induction of of hemodic
stem cells so far even earlier the
induction of hemogenic endothelium so
the precursor value of these of these
hemorrhabidic stem cells
um
and
the data shows here that that's on day
seven we
indeed
have a
cell site that's that
is in line with you with the idea that
these are these cells are hemogenic
endothelium so cd34 positive
45 negative and
positive for endothelial markers like
cd144
but then upon further treatment with the
corresponding
cocktail of molecules um
this phenotype switches from to uh to a
cd4 104 negative cd45
positive so in line with the
switch to an
um hsc identity and then take these
cells which are naturally 3d
cells suspension cells and so we then
differentiate these cells further in in
3d format
into nk cells for example
um and
just
another
quick slide here on the genetic
engineering
activities at catholic so you're
building currently building workflows
for gene editing
for knocking out genetic efficiency but
also for knocking in
genes into into
specific sites in the genome we're
trying again to
build up efficient and robust reliable
workflows
that then later on able to use for our
own internal
aims but also to offer it to
to partners and clients
outside curtin um so the data here shows
you the um the double knockout of hla
class 1 class 2 in the context of
creating universal so-called universal
ips cells
and it shows you that we've
successfully isolated
homozygous
double knockout clones and the fox data
here on the right hand side basically
validates that so the wildhat ips cells
upon stimulation within the phone gamma
induced hla class 1 but but the knockout
clones obviously
failed to do so and likewise with hla
class 2
in this case
expression in the in the ips cell ground
stage was was
was very minimal so we differentiated
the cells into endothelial cells
according to our
our new protocol
um and then at least we obtained partial
induction of hla class 2 which i think
was sufficient to show that
the um
the knockout flaws are indeed uh
deficient of hla class 2.
so um
we're quite optimistic that this
presents a good basis for for gmp
workflow in or gmp like workflow in this
in the future
so just to briefly summarize uh we have
um ips cells generated under gmp
conditions we are offering these ips
cells
to
license an informal basis basis for
for future
clinical workflows
and at the same time we're also offering
basically the workflows themselves as we
have set them up so custom reprogramming
or
qc
services around the core workflow
um and the current activities are really
focusing more and more on
differentiation
protocols and uh
gmp combined workflows based on these on
these protocols
uh as well as on gene editing so we hope
hope to to be able to offer
in the future really um
uh yeah attractive
protocols workflows
to
partners and to actually
right now also partnering in the
development
stage
yeah so thank you very much for your
attention hope this was interesting and
happy to make questions
well many thanks boris for the great
talk and i think the workflows that you
just presented on gmp compliant human
ipsc generation expansion and the
quality control analysis at catalans and
gene therapy set great examples in the
field and think you know all of us we
can learn a lot from your work
and also thanks for the nice
introduction in the beginning so my name
is chow chung and i am the global
product manager for regenerative
medicine manufacturing at milton e
belltech so and now actually i would
also very quickly introduce the
established workflows at milton belteck
for automated closed and gmp compliant
manufacturing of human propulsion stem
cells
first very briefly a few key facts about
mutiny bell tech
so the company was funded in 1989 and
currently has more than 3 500 employees
worldwide and among them 25 are located
in our global r d department who are
constantly advancing our knowledge
in various fields including regenerative
medicine
well speaking of manufacturing of pscs
and their derivatives for clinical
applications so we all know that you
know they are very challenging and
complex endeavors and most of the
current manufacturing processes involve
multiple
very expensive instruments very skilled
operators and high class clean rooms and
also many separated open handling steps
are also introduced in these workflows
meanwhile
standard in-process control and quality
control assets are required throughout
the entire processes
in addition well in certain applications
the desired cell populations also need
to be isolated in a stereo gentle and
gmp compliant environment
so all these factors together could
really limit the manufacturing skill
compromise the reproducibility at the
same time drive up the manufacturing
cost
so how to make these very complex cell
manufacturing processes standardized
scalable and also more affordable for
the end users
and here there are some solutions from
mutiny bell tech
so
with the climax prodigy the separated
open handling steps
multiple devices skilled operators and
high class clean rooms they can be
integrated into one automated enclosed
system and the users could build
customized psc expansion and
differentiation processes with the clean
max prodigy
with the max quant analyzer then
standardized ipcq css can be realized by
automated flow cytometry analysis
and finally the max quant title cell
salter can be applied to isolate the
desired cell populations with a gentle
fast and gmp confined cell sorting
technology
and today actually we will focus on the
climax prodigy
so together with the single-use tubing
set the clean max prodigy allows
automated cell processing from starting
materials to final products upon your
request it can automate all these
different handling steps including
sample preparation density
decentrification cell washing etc until
final product formulation
and based on the clean macrology
platform we have also developed a broad
range of software applications for
various cell types for example for car t
cells and for the ethereum cell types
such as pscs and their derivatives so we
have developed the adherence of culture
process
using the clean maxology adherence cell
culture process
cell cultivation can take place in two
different units the central code unit
and the external cultural vessels so
first there is a clean max strategy
chamber lies inside the centricle unit
it supports automated adherent and the
non-adherence of cultivation so the
centrical unit also supports controls of
the temperature and the concentrations
of air and co2 so this climax prodigy
chamber offers 100 square centimeter
surface space
well if larger surface space is required
then external culture vessels can also
be easily connected to the k-max prodigy
tubing set via serial welding for
example these multi-layer cell stacks so
the users can connect maximumly three of
these five layers of stacks at the same
time this will offer roughly ten
thousand square centimeter surface space
so actually when we designed this
software so our goal is actually to make
sure that it is flexible enough to
culture different cell types so that is
why we modularize the individual cell
handling steps now you can find these
different modules on the main manual for
density gradient centrifugation for
inoculation for coating medium change
harvest etc and the users can freely
select and combine these different
modules as a result very complex
workflows such as directed
differentiation of pcs can be realized
on the climate strategy actually in cell
culture process
within each module the users can also
set up the parameters according to their
established sops for example in a coding
module the user can set up the coding
temperature coating time the volume of
the coating reagents or according to
their established sops
so
we have established workflows for gmp
compliant expansion of human mses and
pses as well as different directed
differentiation of pcs into mid-brain
dominergic progenitors and
cardiomyocytes so next we will quickly
show you some results on gmp compliant
psc expansion using the climax prodigy
so for this workflow we have first
developed the ips blue gmp medium which
is manufactured and tested under the
quality management system iso 13485 and
is designed following the
recommendations of usp1043
on athenary materials so it is currently
available in bottles but very soon we
will also offer the medium in back
format
so we just saw in boris's talk where
they use this medium for gmp compliant
ipsc manufacturing so in our experiment
the result shows that this medium
enables very stable and efficient human
pse expansion as clusters or as single
cells so it also supports fast cultural
reinitiation after cryo preservation
and it is based on actually the same
formulation as our research grade stemx
ips blue xenoframe medium thus can
support seamless transitions from
research to gmp compliant processes
then by applying this ips bluetooth
medium on the close and automated clean
macrology itunes or cultural process the
users now can choose and combine these
different modules to automate all these
complex handling steps for example
coating pse inoculation medium change
and harvesting etc
we have also performed side by side
comparisons between manual and climax
prodigy based pse expansion using our
affinity recombinant antibodies and the
stemx to a lineage differentiation kit
and looking at the expression levels of
the proportionacy markers and the trial
lineage differentiation potentials so
these two groups they claim macrology
versus manual control so they really
give rise to very comparable results
then by using the centric code unit and
the different the different sizes of
external cultural vessels the users can
also easily reach different pse
expansion skills on the climax prodigy
with much less open handling steps in
comparison to the manual process
we know that establishing gmp compliant
pse banks is a
very important step in many clinical
applications so for this purpose we
closed an automated clean macrology at
human cell culture process together with
the ips blue gmp medium and our qc
reagents so they could be very valuable
assets
here uh just a
very quick just very quick example so
recently dr rafael crowe from the
thyroid foundation in japan has
successfully transferred their manual
clinical grade ips expansion workflow
into the climate prodigy adherence of
cultural process so he has already
presented his work at the iser 2021
tokyo symposium and also had a joint
webinar with us last year
well actually that's already all from my
side today so this is the disclaimer of
my presentation
so thanks a lot for your attention i'm
i'm very much looking forward to
discussing with you in the q a session
well if you are interested in any
individual meetings to discuss how to
adapt your established manual process on
the kmac prodigy so please contact me by
email at chaos miltoni.com thanks a lot
and looking forward to discussing with
you later thanks a lot
thank you boris and ciao for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
will the new ips brew gmp medium in bags
have the same formulation as the current
medium
well
i actually i can maybe quickly comment
on that question so i mean the short
answer is yes so the formulation will
stay the same so the only thing is that
you know in this new back format that
the cytokine tj beta 1 will be already
included in the supplement so that the
users they do not need to add the
cytokine additionally
all right thank you
next question
will the clinton max prodigy affect the
plural potency properties of pscs during
the automated expansion process
well i mean i think this is maybe i can
also uh quickly comment on this i think
this is a
very very important question so um you
know for the manufacturing then you know
quality is really the key uh factor so
um as i i think briefly mentioned in the
uh
in my presentation so the the psc is
that we
we expanded using the climax prodigy
adherence our culture process so they
show actually very high expression
levels of these propolency markers they
include the triband 60 ssev4 ssd5 oct4
or sox2 so and they are also able to
differentiate into all the three germ
layers upon differentiation and at the
same time so when we compare the cells
that are expanded manually and we see
that these two groups that they are very
comparable in terms of in terms of the
proponency marker expression and the
tri-lineage differentiation potentials
so that you know based on these
experiments so we believe that you know
the psc's that
they i mean they maintain their
proponency uh properties during the
automated expansion in the closed climax
prodigy
platform
[Music]
all right
our next question is
do you have medium for serum friend
human myoblast expansion
well um
i believe maybe um i can just quickly
comment so i think i need to double
check this so i mean uh if i find more
information then i could have you know
maybe answer your via email or quickly
we can also
discuss this via email
all right thank you
next question
does the clinimax enable any in-process
monitoring of cell media such as ph
do glucose or lactate
well
at the moment so
what we could do on the climax prodigy
when we manufacture the cells is that we
have the sampling pouches so that every
time when you passage the cells that you
know you could uh collect a sample then
you know then you could measure these uh
these factors you mentioned like phdo
glucose lactate etc uh in a collective
sample so this is at the moment how how
we uh what how we can achieve this but
of course and we are working on you know
how to improve to have a more precise uh
in process monitoring after doing the
cell manufacturing
all right thank you
next question
apart from the complementarity of
different cell lines in terms of hla
haplotypes do your cell lines differ
from one another
in other e.g differentiation or
properties
yeah but the question it goes to me
yeah i mean of course they do uh differ
to some extent i mean the salons if you
will they are individuals right they're
they are isolated from different
different people
and we've seen many times that um
you know the the genetic background is
really the main determinant of
satellite properties in principle if you
use a stringent protocol for
differentiation
uh that should actually make no
difference between cell lines but
they're you know
good protocols i would say less
stringent ones
and the less stringent differentiation
protocols will certainly also reveal
these kind of differences
now overall we've shown the cells are
really important
but
there may be differences in
differentiation capacity depending on
which protocol you're using
all right thank you
next question
you highlighted a lower mutation load in
your ipscs as compared to other lines
i did not quite understand how you could
put that down to the starting material
could you please explain this a little
more
uh yeah so what we've done is we've made
a
[Music]
mutation loads comparison between our
cells and and published cells and what
you can do there is really also uh look
into the frequency at which these
mutations occur in the in the cell
population and what you normally assume
is that if a mutation was present in the
starting material then it should be
present
in the in the cell population that you
analyzed by either 50 50 of the
heterozygous or 100 is a homozygous
mutation and if you use that as a
criterion
you can then distinguish between
mutations that have been present already
in the founder cell
of a ips line and mutations that have
only arisen later
so
using that we could then
boil these differences down
to
differences in the starting material
rather than
differences
in the in the manufacturing process so
it's really the the cold blood
source we think that makes the
difference here
all right thank you next question
what is the cell count capacity for the
current prodigy platform
well maybe i can also quickly comment on
that question so i mean this is really
depends so what cell type that you are
you like you are culturing you know with
the clinton max prodigy platform so as i
showed in in our case this time with
about the proposed stem cells so using
this adherence cell culture process that
you can actually connect the external
cultural vessels like the cell stacks
to really enlarge the the surface space
of your cell cultivations so then that
means that you know the cell name the
total cell number the skill and also
depends on the you know what kind of
cell culture vessel that you that you
are using for your process for example
if you're using the the chamber which is
already
part of the the tubing set so this
chamber has 100 square centimeter so
that if you culture the pscs so we
normally uh like inoculate around 1
million ipscs and then upon the cod you
know once they get confluent then when
you harvest the cells normally you could
reach roughly you know five times ten to
the seven uh proposing stem cells in the
chamber but when you are further
expanded to for example one layer sales
tax maybe then you could uh reach like
200 2 times 10 to the 8 so 200 million
pse's and then if you use the five layer
sales tag which you know has much bigger
surface space then you you know when you
harvest yourself then you could probably
reach already uh one billion one-time
single deny proportions themselves uh
when you harvest the cells but of course
you know this depends we know that
there's very like you know some um uh
differences between different
pse cell lines so that also depends on
the cell line how many cells that you
can harvest and how many the cell
numbers that you can harvest
at the end of your process
do you want
chow do you have any final comments for
our audience
well i mean like i mentioned so i mean
if i just uh just a quick comment from
my side in the end so i mean many thanks
to labruz and also we thank a lot to
boris you know for for his very nice and
very informative
presentation
showcasing the gmp compliant ipsc
manufacturing platform at the
catalans and gene therapy so i mean i
think we we all share the same
excitement
in the field uh because we see that you
know there so many centers right now are
trying to translate
their uh research expertise their
experiences into clinical applications
for the treatment of you know some
devastating diseases so and we are also
very happy that uh
our products our technologies you know
could support the customers in their in
their processes so um
just as boris mentioned so for example
the ipc bluetooth medium could be a
great asset for you know for gmp
compliant uh expansion manufacturing of
uh human propulsion stem cells so i mean
if you have you know if you're
interested in these technologies from us
like this medium or like the climax
prodigy there's a manufacturing platform
so then we could you know also discuss
this in a
individual meeting via email so my email
address is very easy to remember it's
chaos at miltoni.com
so uh actually michelle i think there is
one more
question
yes one question just came back in
um
given that a derivation a few ipsc
clones from one patient cost around
ten dollars
how high cost
ten or ten thousand okay i saw the
period and i was thinking
how high cost would the cost be under
gmp conditions comparing also cost today
and envisioned in a couple of years when
the technologies become more routine
well i think this is definitely a great
question from daniel uh but i think uh
maybe boris can have a um
a much more informative answer to this
specific question yeah because i think
that the the the cost or the cost of
good for the manufacturing of the gmp
compliant ipsc lines like in i mean i
think global wise is around 10 to 15 000
us dollars but you know it is decided by
manufacturers and it probably is also
vastly different between different
countries
all right well then we will leave that
question for boris to address
via email
well thank you again boris and ciao for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor miltoni biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you